NetherRealm Studios is working on a
sequel to injustice gods among us it's
fighting game set in the DC comic book
universe I'm Dave and welcome to your
heroic fighting news update citing
sources familiar with the project French
gaming website game blog to Fr reports
the sequel is in development for
playstation 4 xbox one and pc the
unnamed source is added that the sequel
will be announced soon and is aiming for
release in March 2017 as of yet neither
the developer nether realm nor the
publisher Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment have officially teased
plans for injustice gods among us to
gain SWAT has contacted Warner Brothers
for a statement the first injustice gods
among us was released in april 2013 for
xbox 360 playstation 3 and pc an
ultimate edition featuring improved
visuals and all post-release
downloadable content was later launched
on ps4 and Xbox one injustice takes
place in an alternate universe where the
Joker unleashes a nuclear bomb on
metropolis and tricks Superman into
killing Lois Lane and his son in
response Superman establishes himself as
hide councilor of a world government and
begins what some to believe a
dictatorship Batman leads a group of
rebel forces and the heroes and villains
at the DC Universe are forced to take
sides the video game also spawned a
successful critically acclaimed comic
book series which is scheduled to end
this year so do you think the fights
between Superman and Batman in game
would be better than in the most recent
movie let us know in the comment section
below or find me on Twitter at irregular
Dave and fall your gaming news stay
tuned to gamespot com
you